please welcome back
chickpea the Superbowl predicting
chicken this is chickpea and if you
don't have HGTV trust me it's a real
chicken say hi to everybody chickpea
okay congrats on predicting the Super
Bowl correctly how did you know the
Patriots were gonna win what was your
system okay a PowerPoint presentation
will tell us chickpea through excellent
puppeteering is telling us that the
weather in Phoenix was mild which
favored the team there were like more
heavily on their passing attack and that
Bill Belichick's record the playoffs the
Patriots was 20 and 8 another advantage
for the Patriots Brady had a higher
quarterback rating this season than
Russell Wilson and the Patriots were
able to overcome any distractions from
deflategate
what's that chickpea what are you saying
mom you love to bet on sports as well
well you must have made a lot of money
betting on the Super Bowl huh no you got
cold feet yesterday and you bet against
the Patriots a lot of money oh my god
there's the chicken Russian mob to
collect say you thought this might
happen you've got it taken care of
what's that just needs me something
pointing at there what is it you brought
backup look it's a chicken supper
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody that's really stupid
you